foreign
and talk to Chris what's up Chris
hey thanks for taking my call man you
got it what's up man
so uh last week my car actually got
repossessed uh what happened man
uh I knew that I was behind those
payments I just didn't realize how far I
was
and uh can I ask you a hard question
came true can I ask you a real hard
question yeah why did you choose to not
know
you made a choice to avoid how bad it
was yeah yeah I was avoiding it man to
avoid reality how come how come
I guess to to cope with like the stress
from it and uh like the not having
enough money I guess because I knew I
was already paying it and uh for the car
and uh whenever it got repossessed
that's sort of felt almost relieved in a
way of course yeah
you know but uh shame sits in something
fierce huh
I don't know how you knew I was going to
say that man bro dude because I mean
it's like it's like the
uh it's the self-fulfilling prophecy
right like I'm gonna avoid it I'm gonna
avoid it I'm gonna avoid it it happens I
told you you were a loser
we should have bought this car because
we're dumb we don't make enough money
because we're a loser and then the bank
can't even trust us yeah it's just a
loop right
and then here's your next step and tell
me if I'm wrong the next step is you
wallow in it for a few days you like
make snow angels in the shame and you
figure out a way to numb it out either
you drink it away or you Netflix it away
or you're just going out your Bros in a
way and then you find yourself like
without a car and then the next move is
to go do something stupid like go to a
Payday lender or go to one of those the
guys on the side of the highway that's
at like 35 interest on a car note right
yeah I've been I've been sleeping on it
and uh Chris don't do that don't do that
don't do that don't do that please God
don't do that okay
right okay don't do that like it's all
right the house fell down don't burn it
down you can still put it back up okay
cool
all right before we even get going to
your question I want you to hear
the reason I can just track here's how
this whole thing spins out and here's
where you're about to head and you're
like uh yeah actually
is I've taken this call a jillion times
what does that mean it means you're not
alone that means you did something dumb
but you're not stupid
that means you're in a hole but that's
not where you live you're not a Hobbit
okay
thank you man there's a light on the
back end of this thing you just need to
shake the cobwebs off and I love you
enough to both like kind of give you a
hard time about it and also let's let's
get a road map out of here is that cool
yeah all right so um they come and take
your car then what
so uh my parents are my neighbors and my
dad happened to be awake whenever the
guy was uh replenished and I thought he
was going to be mad at me because he had
no idea that I was behind my payments
and I kind of as they were pulling away
I had to explain to whole thing to him
right then and there and uh
it just surprised me right away he was
like well you got to go to work don't
you you can go ahead and take my car and
uh
when I got to work I just tried not to
think about it
and my brother has an extra car and he
said hey you can uh
take uh
take that car and use it to you to save
us some money
and I wasn't I just wasn't expecting
that man and
I in a way it made me feel
really guilty because I'm in this
situation and I have all these people
that want to help me
and hold on that's not what you feel I
don't think that's what it is
I think you feel this weird gnarly sense
of shame because you don't think you're
worthy of that much love
and your old and your old man does and
your brother does
they love you way the hell more than
Chris loves Chris
Fair
yeah yeah
you're right
where did that story come why did Chris
start talking trash to Chris
ha ha
wait
all year I've been trying to better
myself man and uh
work on like my anger issues and
discipline and
self-love uh I got your book back in
March knowing your past change your
future
and I had to put it down because it just
started getting really real man yeah
dude you are a master class in avoidance
you could take my life from me you could
take my car for me but I will not look
under the hood man like you bought a new
car and you just duct taped over the uh
the gas gauge I don't wanna know I don't
know
yeah and it's it's really catching up
with me that's right it always does how
old are you
I'm 28. dude you won the lottery man
because it usually catches most people
when they're 51. and their wife leaves
them and they get fired and they got
nowhere to go
I'm excited for you
yeah and like I feel like my my wife
notices that I've changed a lot I
noticed that I changed a lot and like
when we look at old pictures
um
we can see the difference in my face
like I'm not angry like I used to I used
to get and this whole time this whole
past weekend she's been trying to tell
me you know don't stress out don't
don't let it get you mad we'll get
through it like we always do and uh just
great support and this past week was my
my daughter's first week of school and
it was also the day they got repossessed
with our nine year anniversary together
and I feel like it's it's tainted now
because of this whole situation and this
is where this is where you start this is
your starting line
yeah it's a new starting line that's it
it's not the it's not the it's not where
the race finished this is where the
sucker begins
this is on your 19th anniversary when
you point back you're like remember
where we were
you know what I'm saying yeah you can't
let this this is a big moment right this
is a big moment but you can't let this I
mean bro look what you just rattled off
in front of me
you've been married almost a decade
which is unheard of these days because
people think so little of Covenant
you have a wife that is holding your
hand through hell
you have an old man who's holding your
hand through hell you have a brother who
said here's a car you have a daughter
who's starting school who's healthy
enough to go to school
yeah I'm really grateful man
but all you could think of is I'm such a
loser
that's that's when I'm alone
or when I look in the mirror it's like
that's whenever of the it all sits in
and then when I go to my family I sort
of like I don't want to say I fake it
but I I do you fake it with everybody
man
you think with everybody
thank you with a bank figure with your
old man think with your brother fake it
with your wife take it with your
daughter and I'll tell you this they all
know
they all know
and they don't know exactly what you're
wrestling with but they know
and I'll tell you like the the big
problem with the like self-help like
Flex it out movement
is that it doesn't it often allows
people to skip over dealing with the
core issue
and then you end up with a hundred
thousand dollars in a six-pack abs and
you freaking hate yourself
and so you have to do those things out
of a sense of I'm worth a different kind
of life
not if I get these things then I'll have
a different life because you won't
you'll the same dude will just show up
the same guy who hates himself will show
up
that makes sense and it sounds so cheesy
to say that bro trust me I know it does
but it just sounds cheesy but it's just
it's true over and over and over and
over
I remember being in the car when the
head of publishing my buddy Preston
handed me his cell phone with the email
on it that said hey your book has gone
number one
and I was super excited and then
instantly after that he handed that to
me the phone rings and it was Dave my
boss and he calls me and I was so
excited then I called my mom and my wife
I called my wife and then my mom
and then dude I didn't have anybody else
to call
that same lonely dude who tells
everybody to not be lonely showed up
with the number one book in the country
see what I'm saying like I got it and
then and I got it
and I went with me
yeah
so I tell you you go with you up and you
go with you down
so tell me
what is it about Chris that you wish was
different right now you wish you made
more money he wish your career was
different what is it
no I love my career I make uh I make
decent money what do you do I'm a
machinist
oh so you're one of those guys that can
actually do something with their life
that's pretty cool I love what I do man
dude I'm a podcaster for God's sake you
can build a machine that's amazing man
all right what else
what do you wish I could get my money
right okay
what is it about your money that's
that's off
are you buying stuff to flex out for
people to show them that you're to try
to convince them you're more what is it
no I feel like I've made a lot of bad
decisions in the uh over the past eight
years of uh
overspending on food and getting loans
here and there buying cars with
ridiculous payments and uh I know but
but
what is that car getting you
nothing I just I at the time I thought
it was a good decision and I got a bad
deal on it and made a mistake and then
started resenting it and trying to hide
from it okay
so step one of All Wellness whether that
you're trying to lose weight whether
you're trying to make money whether
you're trying to get right spiritually
whether you're trying to get right
psychologically and emotionally
is choosing reality I have to choose to
live in reality this is the state of
things the reason I'm asking about your
money is are you is it like a matter of
like I thought this was a good idea and
then I got into it and oh my gosh
it wasn't a good idea which means it's a
it's it's knowledge it's Insight I don't
have the right Tools in front of me
um I thought this was the right machine
to use and ended up I should have used
this machine is it that or is it impulse
control and you're just kind of acting
like a toddler when it comes to your
money
uh it's a little bit of all like because
I know I do have impulse and I know that
uh
I made like
financing sounds so good in the moment
all right so here's here's how I've
handled financing in my life
um
I will never willingly chain my family
to a bank again
yeah I will never willingly chain myself
to somebody who gives me money for a
depreciating asset which is what a car
loan is every day I own that it's worth
less money and that banknote continues
to stay the same
I just refuse to put my I refuse to be
owned
see what I'm saying and so it's not
about like I don't know about Finance I
don't know if that's a good deal no no I
refuse
to participate in
modern day slavery after I refuse to
participate
what does that mean sometimes in my life
the cars I've driven have been so
embarrassing
like bro they're bad like they're back
I've had buddies like take me I'll be
like hey are you okay I do great that's
not I don't care about my cars
and I don't spend a lot of money on my
clothes I mean it's like it's and we can
go on and on and on
but my identity is in my wife loves me
my Denny's and my kids love me and
they're safe my identity is I do a good
job at my job I do good work and I'm a
trustworthy Integris person my identity
is in my faith and so when I have those
things
need a lot of crap but I tell you this
to tell you there's a map out I'm gonna
send you for free I'm gonna send you all
of Financial Peace University the whole
kitten caboodle and I'm gonna send you
um one year of every dollar okay
it's the best financial tool in the
world and you link it up with your wife
and when both of you spin it goes off
each other's app and it pulls it tells
you from your it can connect with your
bank and does all that together okay
okay
you know but what but here's the deal I
want you to watch those lessons with
your wife on the couch and if your kid's
old enough make them sit on and watch
them too so this stuff ends with you
yeah I just I don't want my kids seeing
money is a bad thing and I'm trying
that's part of me like hiding it I guess
but they they here's the deal bro they
feel it
yeah they know Dad can't breathe they
know Dad is stressed and they know Dad
can't sit still in the room because he's
worried and worried and worried and
worried
it was in Houston and money was always
always a stressor always
and I grew up hating money because of
what it did to my dad
for what it told me about my family that
we were somehow worth less than my
neighbors
I hated it man
and I'm in my 40s and I'm just now
figuring out money is just a tool that's
it
in a shiny car is cool if you pay for it
in cash and you got a whole bunch of
other assets somewhere otherwise it's
just stupid
see what I'm saying yeah it's a total
flip
but I think beneath all that so I'm
gonna give you the tools on the money
side dude if you will follow those money
principles my promise to you is in 15
years You're Gonna Be a Millionaire
that's probably a little bit overstated
you may not be I can't promise you that
you're gonna have a totally different
position okay
but
you have to do the work on making peace
with Chris
because Chris is a good guy
and Chris is a good no no no no no no no
no don't do that
you're deflecting again Chris is a good
guy
he's got a good brother and he's got a
good old man and they're not perfect
and he's a good husband
and he's doing his best to be the best
dad he can be even though he doesn't
know what he's doing
and he's made some stupid decisions with
money the difference between guilt and
shame is that was stupid versus I'm
stupid
yeah you're right you did some dumb
stuff all right I'm gonna learn from
that same as when you're trying to teach
an apprentice in the Machine Shop they
do something dumb you're like dude don't
do that again do it like this and they
go oh okay cool
yeah same
at least treat yourself at least talk to
yourself at least love yourself as much
as your dad does much as your brother
does
much as your co-workers do at least if
not more is that fair
yeah no that's fair man
it's it's it's tough trying to love
yourself whenever you don't
I guess the expectations you want to be
that's right and so let's be super clear
because a lot of the times this stuff
gets real heavy I want you to spend a
season writing this crap down
like write down the answer to what does
success look like in my home and if
success is has anything to do with
square footage or wheels on a car that
go round and round and round
um you've got that thing sideways
like I mentioned and
I just don't know why I can't just uh be
happy with myself
well I think you've got some confidence
issues man because confidence only comes
from a bunch of little successes and
you've had a bunch of stumbles man you
had a bunch of like man shouldn't have
done that
it's like my my winds aren't equally out
to my losses yeah dude because you keep
borrowing money on depreciating assets
and they're not even paying on it I mean
it's not hard it's pretty it's pretty
simple
so here's what I want you to do I want
you to get some of your dignity back you
know what that's going to look like it's
going to look like this I want you to
call your brother
and say
um can I have this car for 12 months
and if he's like man that's a long time
like I know I'm gonna pay you I'm gonna
pay you 100 a month and I know that's
not even close to what it's worth
but I need some sort of I gotta have
some skin in the game here so I'm gonna
give you 100 bucks a month
just for renting this car from you
and then I want you to pick up an extra
shift and an extra shift and I want you
to get 3 500 cash as quick as you can
okay and I don't want you I want you to
stay as far away from those stupid Lots
as you possibly can once you get on a
Facebook Marketplace and I want you to
buy a 3500 Camry
and they are going to rag you when you
pull up to that shop oh my gosh they're
gonna give it to you
but you know what you're not gonna owe
nobody nothing
you're right nothing
and you can tell your wife sorry dude
you married me
if you married me for my Tahoe then you
may need to find somebody else because
I'm a camera guy for the season
but look like
I want you to drive around a 3500 Camry
for a season man and make peace with it
and then save up cash and get an
emergency fund for your family and pay
off all your stupid credit cards
and what we're doing people make this
all about the well it's APR is here and
if you invested this dude we're not
there
we are I'm choosing freedom in my home
Chris in Houston my family will be
holding to nobody if I get fired from my
job it's going to be their loss and I'm
going to take a week off and kind of
check off the cobwebs and then I'm
finding me a new gig because I got an
emergency fund of my own cash and my own
bank account
I don't need it
I'm squared up
totally squared up
this is about choosing reality here's
the state of things take your wife out
for breakfast one day man
or for lunch God's Papa seed is there in
Houston The Greatest Mexican food places
on planet Earth and just say what do we
want our house to look like and more
importantly what it has to feel like
what does that look like how much money
is that going to require
what kind of cars is that gonna require
it's gonna be a lot different than you
think
let's build a picture together you and
her
and let's start leaning into that and
you're gonna get a bunch of little wins
towards a picture that you and your wife
have chosen a home y'all chosen to build
and dude now you are Off to the Races my
friend
and along the way I want you to remind
Chris
that you're a good man
you didn't think it was going to feel
like this feels different than he's
always going to feel but the proof is in
the pudding got a great wife got a great
kid
got a good family you got a home got a
roof over your head you don't owe nobody
anything
you're a good man Chris